on va parler de la loi immigration
évidemment c'est le jour J pour cette
commission mixte parire chargé de
trouver un accord entre députés et
sénateurs et les tractations se sont
poursuivies encore hier soir à Matignon
3h de négociation entre élzabeth borne
et les républicains et pour Eric CTI on
peut toujours pas parler d'accord on
voit ça avec Adrien P pas encore
d'accord avec la majorité selon Eric CTI
président deslr à quelques heures de la
commission mixte paritaire sur le Tex
immigration les LR était reçu hier soir
à Matignon la troisème fois en moins
d'une semaine le parti souhaite
conserver au maximum le texte du Sénat
plus ferme que le texte d'origine
lesakis a confirmé se dessine en matière
de prestation sociale de déchéance de
nationalité d'exclusion du droit du sol
pour les criminels et de double peine
nous voulons des engagements précis sur
la réforme de l'ame et sur les moyens
d'expulsion des clandestins la
transformation de l'Ame l'aide médicale
d'État pour les étrangers sans papier
est l'un des principaux points de
friction entre LLR et la majorité lesr
sem acccord pour la supprimer du texte
la seule condition qu'une réforme de
l'Ame à part soit prévue dès début 2024
quant au gouvernement il s'estffce de
trouver un accord pour donner un second
souffle à son texte le gouvernement
souhaite un accord avec le Sénat avec
les dirigeants des républicains pour un
texte qui n'est pas qui ne sera pas un
texte parfait mais qui sera un texte
d'accord et je pense que chacun doit
faire un pas faute de majorité en
commission mixte paritaire le camp
présidentiel est contraint de faire
pencher le texte à droite la semain seme
dernière Renaissance avait défini une
liste de mesures répressives du Sénat
qui le refuse parmi ell la condition de
résidence de 5 ans en France pour
toucher des aides sociales ou encore le
durcissement du droit du sol la
présidente de l'Assemblée nationale se
dit toutefois ouverte à des compromis
sur ces sujets moi j'ai rarement de lign
rougees écarlate ça doit coûter à chacun
ça doit coûter à chacun et effectivement
si nous devions aller dans cette
direction ça me coûterait probablement
la commission mixte paritaire se tiendra
à partir de 17h à l'Assemblée nationale
elle pourrait durer jusqu'au bout de la
nuit si un accord n'est toujours pas
trouvé dans la journée Mathie souer
quand on entend à la fois la majorité
présidentielle et l'exécutif et à la
fois les républicains on a l'impression
que tout le monde veut un accord et tout
le monde souhaite sortir de cette CMP
avec un un accord est-ce qu'ils ont trop
à perdre à ne pas trouver d'accord ce
soir je dirais que l'accord en CMP n'est
sans doute pas la chose la plus
difficile à à obtenir mais il y aura
l'accord en cm aujourd'hui et puis il y
a la question du coup du vote euh par
l'Assemblée et par le Sénat demain euh
il y a forcément un petit sentiment de
malaise et encore une fois même si la
CMP devait être conclusive aujourd'hui
euh la probabilité est élevée en ce sens
euh quand même la la journée
d'aujourd'hui couronne une semaine qui
qui imprègne un sentiment de malaise
c'estàdire que on a vu quand même depuis
une semaine un spectacle politique dont
beaucoup ont considérrait qu'il était
avant tout honteux et marqué et par le
une forme d'amateurisme de la part du
gouvernement alors le gouvernement est
certes faible mais on avait le sentiment
enfin on avait cru que que Gérald
haranin était l'homme politique qu'il
nous fallait dans cette séquence
connaissant bien les LR habile
politiquement et donc capable de sceller
un accord avec ses anciens alliés ses
anciens camarades il y a quand même une
dimension d'amateurisme du côté du
gouvernement et une vraie dimension de
cynisme de la part des oppositions genre
on on a une loi immigration qui n'est
pas une loi immigration qui est une loi
antiimmigration disons les choses
franchement quand même et une loi
anti-immigration qui ne devrait en rien
déplaire ni à LR ni même au RN et
pourtant on se retrouve avec LR et RN
qui vote avec la gauche donc je crains
quand même que dans cette affaire et par
amateurisme et par cynisme tous les pans
politiques de de l'hémicycle se soient
déshonorés vous êtes d'accord
amateurisme d'un côté cyisme de l'autre
oui non mais c'est sûr que je suis pas
sûr que les Français s'y retrouvent très
bien là-dedans parce qu'effectivement
tout le monde vote comme un seul homme
contre la
majorité alors que il ne partage
absolument pas les mêmes idées mais ça
c'est pas la première fois d'ailleurs
d'ailleurs il y a déjà eu non pas
des il y a déjà eu des des des
obstructions comme ça au par le passé
depuis le début du quinquena de ce
second quinquena
euh est-ce que le gouvernement est
perdant il est perdant dans tous les cas
quoi qu'il arrive il est perdant parce
que le texte s'il est adopté à l'issue
d'une procédure que Mathieu vient de
présenter mais qui est quand même
compliqué parce qu'il faut encore qu'ils
ait le vote demain hein c'est pas pas
parler euh il y a une majorité la
majorité est très composite elle est
relative et composite donc ils sont
perdants parce que c'est pas le texte
s'il est adopté c'est pas le texte
qu'ils ont
proposé c'est le texte auquel il voulait
échapper justement et si ça passe pas
bah ils sont perdants sur toute la ligne
pour le coup et alors là on peut
considérer qu'il y aura des des
conséquences assez rapides qui seront
catastrophiques pour la majorité
présidentielle et pour le pouvoir
exécutif donc mais ça veut dire pour
vous quoi qu'il en soit c'est une
défaite pour le gouvernement c'est une
défaite pour le gouvernement c'est
évident bah ils ont été obligés de si
vous voulez ils ont été obligés de
battre en retraite en race
campagne pour accepter le chantage de
parce que c'est quand même une forme de
chantage qu'on soit d'accord ou pas avec
les dispositions des
républicains surtout des républicains
d'ailleurs et d'une certaine façon du
rassemblement national c'est quand même
une espèce de surenchère qui a été
exercé par par les droites un complément
peut-être sur ce que dit Yve est-ce que
les Français s'y retrouvent
effectivement alors il y a deux
dimensions on a vu qu'un certain nombre
de sondages disait que l'opinion était
majoritairement favorable à
l'orientation du texte c'està-dire des
éléments de durcissement en matière
migratoire c'est vrai et une majorité de
Français souhaite qu'un texte soit du
coup adopté mais si on prend un tout
petit peu de recul quand même ce qu'on
observe c'est que il y a 18 mois au
moment de l'élection présidentielle
l'immigration ne figurait pas parmi les
préoccupations principales des Français
je ne dis pas du tout que l'immigration
n'existe pas parmi leurs préoccupations
mais elle n'est pas une préoccupation de
rang 1 et je dirais que même je dirais
même que en tendance dans la durée elle
n'est jamais une préoccupation de rang 1
elle existe on en parle beaucoup là et
donc ça n'est pas une préoccupation de
rang 1 or depuis quelques quelques
semaines quelques mois même on ne parle
que de ça le pays ne parle que de ça
première chose et deuxième chose
précisément le spectacle qui a été qui
qui a qui a été donné à voir depuis une
semaine traduit une pratique
parlementaire que les Français en
revanche réprouvent les Français sont
pour précisément la majorité relative et
la nécessité de de faire du dialogue et
de la coconstruction parlementaire une
partie une majorité de Français et même
nostalgique de la cohabitation qui est
un système politique une situation
politique qui précisément garantit une
forme d'équilibre de débat ou en tout
cas voilà qui nous prémunit d'un risque
d'excès de pouvoir donc précisément par
rapport aux attentes des Français il n'y
a pas d'obsession migratoire en France
il y a des préoccupations qui qui sont
très diverses selon les composantes de
la population pour le dire pour le dire
simplement à gauche on s'y intéresse de
loin même dans la majorité
présidentielle en réalité on manifeste
un intérêt pour la question migratoire
sans plus on est très préoccupé par la
question migratoire à droite et on est
obsédé par la question migratoire à
l'extrême droite ce qui ne dit pas que
l'ensemble du pays encore une fois se
réveille tous les matins en pensant à ce
sujet-l alors on est un peu dans un
c'est vrai qu'on est un peu avec un
projet de loi finalement de cohabitation
finalement hein euh c'est comme si on
était en cohabitation c'estàdire que le
Président de la République est obligé de
manger son chapeau et d'accepter un
texte qui n'est pas issu de sa majorité
mais c'est là qu' est l'indignité
démocratique parce que quand même le le
texte qui est sur la table normalement
convient et à LR et à l'extrême droite
et ce sont LR et l'extrême droite qui
font précisément obstruction donc même
Marine Le Pen je ne sais pas dans quelle
mesure elle tire son épingle du jeu ici
alors ça c'est la première des choses la
deuxième des choses sur le fait que
l'immigration soit pas au cœur des
préoccupations des
Français moi je pense que oui je pense
que c'est la principale des
préoccupations actuellement et c'est une
des raisons pour lesquelles le
rassemblement national progresse de la
sorte aucune enquête ne la met en tête
Yve bah oui certes mais c'est de deux ou
troisème sujet important temps euh c'est
c'est toujours dans l'air du temps ça
fait 40 ans que ça c'est jamais sur le
podium il c'est jamais dans les trois
prupations principou ça fait quand même
30 ans que on vit avec ça le le le
rassemblement national fait son commerce
électoral avec ça principalement euh
c'est pas avec la question sociale mais
c'est avec la question identitaire d'une
certaine façon donc il y a ça puis
troisième chose il y a eu une il y a eu
des deux événements ou trois événements
fondamentaux depuis le début du second
quinqued ce sont des attentats
attentats commis comment et par qui par
des gens qui autant il peut y avoir des
attentats qui sont commis par des
Français mais ça peut être aussi des
attentats commis et ça a été le cas et
ça a remis ce sujet sur le sur le devant
de la scène parce que on s'est aperçu
que la la législation française elle
était peut-être tout à fait adaptée si
vous voulez à la situation mais qu' son
exécution et son application était
défaillante et ça je pense que ça a
beaucoup marqué les Français le le le le
il faut quand même penser à Dominique
Bernard qui est mort sous le coup d'un
d'un d'un jeune
homme de façon absolument horrible et ça
je pense que ça a beaucoup choqué les
français ce qui pardon je peux compléter
ce qui est intéressant quand même c'est
que en moyenne durée encore une fois
nous n'avons cessé de nous laisser
imposer le thème de l'immigration par
l'extrême droite on on cite depuis
quelques temps le fait que en 40 ans on
aura fait adopter une trentaine de lois
c'estàdire que tous les 18 mois en
moyenne en fait le Parlement remet le
l'affaire sur la table donc on parle
beaucoup d'immigration et alors qu'il y
a 40 ans on disait que sur ces sujets là
y compris l'extrême droite posait les
bonnes questions mais n'apportait pas
les bonnes réponses quand même
progressivement non seulement
l'immigration est devenue centrale mais
progressivement tout le monde a fini par
tenir un discours qui est censé calmer
les électeurs du rassemblement national
et même je dirais que la gauche ne peut
plus subir le procès en laxisme qu'on
lui a fait pendant longtemps avec
Chevenement hier et avec Manuel Val hier
déjà sur la question migratoire en
réalité la gauche montrait une forme de
respons ilité or l'immigration est
devenue centrale et de plus en plus on
en a parlé y compris avec les termes de
l'extrême droite sans que l'extrême
droite ne recule au contraire l'extrême
droite ne cesse de progresser donc je
dirais même que tactiquement
stratégiquement c'est sans efficacité
oui parce que il y a une défaillance
dans l'application de la loi je dire
c'est c'est c'est l'État est pris en
défaut à chaque fois mais à chaque fois
ça fait quand même on a on a vécu une
cinquantaine d'attentats depuis 2012 et
Moham mer et sur ces cinquantaines sur
cinquantaine d'attentats vous percevez
vous vous apercevez que si vous prenez
pour ceux qui sont des attentats commis
par des étrangers bah vous vous
apercevez qu'il y a des failles
terribles d'où d'ailleurs le lien qui
est fait avec l'insécurité parce
queavant c'était défendu de faire un
lien entre immigration et insécurité
aujourd'hui ce lien est fait mais ça ne
dit pas que nous sommes défaillants
parce qu'en réalité la France n'est pas
plus défaillante que les autres pays
européens par
exemple mais ça dité avec l'ambassadeur
Italie l'ambassadrice d'Italie la
semaine
dernière je lui disais vous avez une
immigration qui est forte en en Italie
très forte puisque c'est une un des pays
les plus exposés à l'arrivée des des
migrants mais j'ai dis vous avez pas ce
problème d'attentat alors je pense qu'il
y a des raisons historiques pour
lesquelles ils n'ont pas ce ce problème
là c'estàdire qu'il y a pas ce passé ce
passé colonial et puis les migrants ne
cherchent pas à rester à s'implanter en
Italie ou moins qu'ailleurs mais ce qui
prouve quand même aussi que et bien on
n'est pas complètement au point
là-dessus on a on a y a des faill énorme
dans mais cette situation existe en
Allemagne en Belgique aux Pays-Bas
également je la France n'est
pas n'est pas le seul pays touché par
cela et ça dit précisément que en dépit
des services de renseignement très
performants que nous avons en dépit de
la police que nous avons qui est plutôt
compétente on peut dire plein de choses
sur le maintien de l'ordre pour autant
la France est un pays plutôt bien
administré en matière égalienne ça dit
que y compris un pays comme le nôtre ne
peut pas se garantir en réalité de tout
risque de de toute menace en dépit de
toutes les lois qu'on fait adopter tous
les 18 mois on va revenir à cette
commission mix parita Alex on va dire un
mot du profil de ces 14 parlementaires
qui vont se réunir tout à l'heure
effectivement d'abord un mot sur le
rapport de force au sein de cette
commission mixte paritaire qui est
composé de je le rappelle de 14
parlementaires dont C parlementaires de
la droite et 5 de la majorité
présidentielle alors on va déjà regarder
l'équipe de la majorité présidentielle
on commence par Sacha alier député
Renaissance président de la commission
des LO ancien socialiste c'est l'une des
figures de l'aile gauche de la majorité
présidentielle et dans ce débat sur le
texte immigration et bien il veut tout
faire pour remanier le projet de loi
durci par la droite sénatoriale ensuite
il y a Florent bouer député Renaissance
rapporteur du projet de loi à
l'Assemblée nationale c'est lui qui a
réécrit en commission des lois à
l'Assemblée l'article du texte sur la
régularisation des travailleurs sans
papi dans les métiers en tension
l'objectif c'était de ne pas trop
s'éloigner de la version du Sénat et en
même temps de conserver l'unité de la
majorité présidentielle et puis pour
représenter l'aile droite de renaissance
et bien il y aura Marie gevennou elle
fait partie de l'équipe de campagne de
François Fillon en 2017 enfin dans la
majorité présidentielle on peut aussi
citer la députée modem Elodie jaquier
Laforge car le parti le modem le parti
de François Baayou et bien un rôle à
jouer aussi dans ce débat car il
souhaite un texte équilibré et pas trop
droitier et pour les sénateurs
Renaissance et bien ce sera Olivier Bitz
on note que les sénateurs Renaissance
ont voté au Sénat tous les les
durcissements proposés par la droite
hormis la restriction de l'aide médicale
d'État Alex la compo de l'effectif dans
l'équipe de droite et bien à droite le
capitaine de l'équipe est plutôt connu
hein c'est Bruno rotao le président du
groupe les républicains au Sénat et ce
n'est pas l'usage car il ne fait pas
partie de la commission des lois mais il
a demandé expressément assiéger dans
cette commission mixte paritaire pour
peser sur la négociation et défendre la
version durcie du projet loi voté par la
droite sénatoriale ensuite il y a le
président de la commission des lois le
sénateur les républicains François Noël
buffet c'est un spécialiste des
questions migratoires et son travail a
notamment beaucoup inspiré le projet de
loi de géralde d'armanin François Noël
buffet lui souhaite véritablement qu'il
y ait un accord entre la droite et la
majorité présidentielle les députés les
républicains seront représentés par
Annie jeunevar qui a de l'expérience et
son 3è mandat elle est favorable au
texte du Sénat et puis s'il y a accord
charge à elle ensuite de convaincre les
députés de son groupe de voter le texte
demain de manière unie ce qui n'est pas
toujours le cas pour les sénateurs
centristes qui parti de la majorité du
Sénat et bien place au rapporteur du
projet de loi Philippe boncarer qui
était sur ce plateau ce matin Philippe
boncarrer qui défend et la nécessité
d'un accord et également la nécessité de
la mesure de régularisation des
travailleurs sans papier dans les
métiers en tension et puis à gauche on
peut également citer les deux sénatrices
socialistes Marie-Pierre de la Gonterie
Corine nassiguin la députée insoumise
André torina donc trois parlementaires
de gauche opposé au texte tout comme le
député du rassemblement national Johan
julet qui siège dans cette commission
mixte paritaire ce jeune député de 37
ans et bien défendra la position du RN
qui est de s'opposer à ce projet de loi
qu'il ne juge pas assez ambitieux même
dans la version du Sénat if ça va se
jouer entre la majorité présidentielle
et la majorité sénatoriale de la droite
et du centre est-ce que comp tenu du
profil des parlementaires qui siègent il
y a plutôt une tendance favorable à un
accord ou est-ce que les républicains
risquent de faire monter encore les
enchères bah je pense qu'ils vont faire
encore un peu monter les enchères si
vous voulez mais euh il devrait pouvoir
trouver un accord je pense que le le
l'exécutif apparaît comme tout à fait
ouvert je dirais à des évolutions il va
y avoir un des sujets centraux c'est
l'histoire de la l'aide médicale d'État
apparemment madame born s'est engagé à
ce qu'il y a un texte distinct qui soit
examiné au premier trimestre de l'année
prochaine donc tout ça ça devrait
permettre de de de d'arriver à un accord
le problème ça sera le vote de demain
euh est-ce que la est-ce que la l'aile
gauche comme on dit de la majorité
acceptera de de de de s'abstenir parce
que c'est c'est c'est l'enjeu c'est pas
de V c'est faire en sorte qu'il ne vote
pas contre on en parle dans quelques
secondes du vote de demain Mathieu
est-ce que les républicains ont tant
intérêt que ça à faire monter les
enchères bah enfin encore une fois les
il faut voir de quel républicain on
parle en réalité c'est pour ça que le
débat sur l'immigration m'apparaît à
plein d'égard piégé les républicains
aujourd'hui c'est la ligne cioti et
c'est la ligne retaillot pardon mais il
y a quelques années encore si on bobine
le film y compris en matière migratoire
quand même les grands leaders de la
droite républicaine n'étaient pas sur
cette ligne politique là on a quand même
le sentiment que les républicains de
plus en plus désormais courent derrière
l'extrême droite et là où l'immigration
est en plus un sujet piégé c'est que
elle elle Clive y compris chez ceux
qu'elle devrait mettre d'accord
précisément chez les républicains on a
vu quand même que il y a quelques
semaines il y avait un yatus entre les
sénateurs d'un côté et les députés de
l'autre on a observé exactement le même
clivage d'ailleurs au sein de la
majorité présidentielle où les Sénat
n'ont pas voulu voter la même chose que
ce que les députés précisément voulaient
alors les LR pour des pour des raisons
tactiques et au sein de la majorité
présidentielle pour des raisons de fond
pour des raisons de désaccord de fond
mais on voit bien que le le terrain est
totalement miné pour autant pour encore
une fois la la des raisons des raisons
tactique on imagine bien que la CMP sera
ce soir conclusive alors justement en
cas d'accord c'est pas fini Alex il y a
encore des obstacle à passer hein
effectivement tout va se jouer demain
demain en début d'après-midi le Sénat en
cas d'accord devra voter sur les
conclusions de cette commission mixte
paritaire jusque-là pas trop de risque
la majorité de droite et du centre du
Sénat devrait voter hein le projet loi
de compromis qui aura une forte
empreinte de la part des sénateurs et là
où ça se complique c'est demain en fin
d'après-midi à l'Assemblée nationale le
projet de loi devra obtenir les voix
d'une majorité de députés pour être
adopté et il faudra qu'une grande partie
de la majorité présidentielle vote ce
texte marqué par les durcissements de la
droite on sait que des députés de
l'aelle gauche de renaissance pourrait
refuser de le voter on regardera
également le groupe modem qui pèse une
cinquantaine de députés et qui aura
également son importance hein il veut un
texte équilibré au final le calcul est
assez simple hein la cinquantaine de
voix de députés LR qui pourrait être
gagné avec cet accord ne doit pas être
perdu de l'autre côté au sein de la
majorité présidentielle sinon le texte
sera rejeté car le gouvernement écarte 1
493 et en cas de rejet du texte et bien
la macronie entrera dans une profonde
crise politique est-ce qu'il y a un
risque est-ce que le plus dur c'est
demain finalement y bah oui je pense que
le plus dur c'est demain le plus dur
c'est demain même si le ton n'est pas
monté jusqu'ici c'estd qu'on a entendu
Sacha Houlier qui était qui se voulait
plutôt conciliant qui est le président
de la commission des lois de l'Assemblée
nationale qui participe à la CMP de ce
soir et qui ne veut pas
justement empêcher le gouvernement
semble-t-il on a entendu François
baayrou hier qui s'exprimait
publiquement et qui n'était pas aussi
remonté qu'on aurait aurait pu
l'imaginer alors que il y avait pas mal
de députés modem qui
étaient assez hostiles à ces
aménagements mais je pense que
l'autorité de François baayrou sur les
modems est forte
donc on va voir mais c'est vrai qu'il y
a un risque quand même demain que
beaucoup de députés de la majorité de la
coalition
présidentielle et bien ne s'abstiennent
pas et votent contre ouais est-ce que
ellisabeth borne chef de la majorité
joue gros et notamment demain Mathieu
alors oui c'est sûr je dirais de toute
façon quoi qu'il se passe aujourd'hui
demain tout le monde perd ça c'est une
certitude même si je dirais même si la
loi est adoptée l'autorité
présidentielle et l'autorité
gouvernementale est de toute façon
fragilisée et même si la loi est adoptée
la cohésion de la majorité elle-même est
mise à mal alors il y aura pas
nécessairement l'expression et et la
dissidence de frondeur dès cette fois-ci
mais ça dit bien quand même que que
quand le le le la le centre de gravité
se déporte trop vers la droite on perd
une partie de ses troupes que le en même
temps qui avait sans doute vécu depuis
longtemps et désormais bel et bien
enterré alors si demain il y avait un
problème il est évident que et
ellisabeth borne et Gérald Darmanin
seraient de toute façon sur la touche et
je dirais même on imagine mal que la
crise politique qui a du coup éclos
quand même la semaine dernière se
prolongeant cette semaine ne se
traduirait pas par une initiative
politique de la part du président de la
République celui qui à ce stade est le
plus affaibli quand même c'est
assurément Gérald Darmanin Gérald
daranin aura vécu quand même un automne
extrêmement pénible et je dirais même
que avec un quelque chose d'un peu
pervers de la part du chef de l'État qui
lui a envoyé la première ministre lors
de sa rentrée politique à tourcoin il y
a quelques semaines pour lui torpiller
sa rentrée politique et qui désormais le
place sous la coupe de la première
ministre pour non seulement négocier les
voix d'un accord mais commencer les
réunions de négociation par des mots
d'excuses présentés officiellement aux
différents partis politiques donc tout
ça quand même traduit pour Gérald d'in
un terrible affaiblissement on suivra
évidemment tout ça sur nos antennes
cette CMP qui commence à partir de 17h
avec des émissions spéciales toute la
soirée Alex avant de se quitter on
regarde si une de nos quotidiens
[Musique]
régionaux pas d'immigration la une de la
presse régionale ce matin mais on parle
d'aviation Alex et oui on va regarder la
Une de La Dépêche du Midi avec cette
information un 4,7 milliards de
personnes de devrait voyager en avion
l'année prochaine un record historique
qui dépasse le niveau d'avant la
pandémie de covid-19 44 % des voyageurs
interrogé par l'Association du transport
aérien international décllar qu'ils vont
voyager davantage en avion que pendant
l'année 2023 he comme si l'ENV l'envie
de découvrir le monde s'était développé
après la période de pandémie et malgré
la hausse du prix du pétrole cela
réjouit les les constructeurs aériens
mais pas forcément ceux qui luttent
contre le réchauffement climatique la
Une de l'Union le fléo de l'obésité chez
les jeunes oui l'obésité atteint des
records dans les Haut- de France et dans
le Grand Est y compris chez les enfants
et les adolescents c'est allé une du
journal L'Union les chiffres sont
inquiétants dans le Grand Est on estime
à
272000 le nombre d'enfants en surpoids
ou en obésité les spécialistes
expliquent que pour sortir ses enfants
de cette situation et bien il faut jouer
sur plusieurs facteurs l'investissement
de la famille la nutrition bien sûr mais
également la dimension psychologique et
il faut du temps hein quand un enfant
est obèse depuis 3 ans il faut au moins
autant de temps pour qu'il sorte de son
obésité on parle santé toujours avec une
belle histoire c'est dans le Télégramme
et oui le vert marin a sauvé un grand
brûlet au CHU de Nantes le pronostic
vital de cet homme était engagé il était
dans le coma mais les pansements qui lui
ont été euh posé les pansements fait à
partir d'hémoglobine de verre marin ont
eu un effet spectaculaire en 2 mois la
la cicatrisation a été réglée l'homme
est sorti du coma il est parti en
rééducation ses pansements euh conçus à
partir de verre marin sont fabriqué par
la société
Arina basée à Morley et c'est la
première fois qu'on les administrit sur
un grand brûet allez Alex pas de foot
cette semaine mais Durand évidemment et
oui puisque l'équipe de France féminine
de handball est sacré championne du
monde c'était hier soir les blelons
emporté 31 à28 en finale contre la
Norvège elle décroche ainsi leur 3è
étoile mondiale et c'est forcément de
bonne augure à 7 mois des Jeux
Olympiques elle a un mot sur Miss France
elle la une de la voie du Nord et oui ça
y est F Gill est entré dans le
tourbillon de Miss France après son
élection samedi soir à l'étagé de 20 ans
elle est origine
de quadrip dans le Nord un petit village
elle suit une licence de mathématique et
de statistique qu'elle reprendra après
son année de Miss France elle a des
messages à faire passer notamment sur le
harcèlement et les critiques sur le
physique merci beaucoup Alex Yve la Une
du Figaro c'est l'immigration dernière
tractation pour sauver la loi
immigration ouis oui effectivement tout
à lire dans Le Figaro Mathieu on remonte
votre livre 2022 la flambée populiste
séchz plomb merci beaucoup Mathie sou
merci d'avoir été avec nous merci Alex
merci à tous nous avoir suivi à 18h vous
avez rendez-vous avec Thomas H pour sens
public on se retrouve demain très bonne
journée